typically when we talk about data
transfer efficiency we're talking about
limiting the amount of data being
transferred that reduces the bandwidth
and the cost and is generally a pretty
good idea but on mobile there's an extra
factor as you can see it turns out that
the cell radio is one of the biggest
battery drainers on the device so making
your data transfers more efficient will
also result in improved battery life now
at a basic level being more efficient
means spending less time transferring
less data reducing your payloads and
updating less often can take you some of
the way there but then what can timing
make a difference it turns out that it
can and it's a situation I like to think
of as the cookie droid can under do we
perform fewer downloads with larger
payloads or do we perform lots of small
transfers just in time for when we need
them one big cookie or lots of little
cookies so what do you think should we
have a smaller number of large downloads
illustrated by this big cookie or a
larger number of small downloads as
illustrated by lots of little cookies